you've been in so many movies that
sometimes I forget oh yeah How to Train
Your Dragon and that franchise is
massive it is you are the voice of
hiccup I know it's huge with let me let
me finish
you are the boss some line we ended
record no but I would just think I mean
my kids absolutely went insane there
there they they just went insane for the
whole series and I know kids love that
kids must lose their minds when they
find out that you are hiccup in theory
usually what happens is a friend of mine
will tell me their kids are big fans and
they hear my voice in their car and
their house all day and only here you
would you mind coming to meet my kid hey
daddy's friends with hiccup and they
look up most underwhelming thing in the
world and then and then and they and
they get me so hey how's it going and
how doesn't he sound like him and I can
see the kid being like you know for my
benefit just trying to be like yeah yeah
I guess it sounds like I'm dad yeah so
it's a terrible I had the experience of
someone like in a checkout line being
like hey you know you know Susan look
who it is
she's like no no tell her who you are
exactly that's the best time it's
friends making you or it's someone else
making it worse time what tell I know
what are you from Belgium tell them what
you're from and then I'm like you want
me to list everything 20 years there's a
lot of them and that is an exercise in
diminishing returns because let me tell
you it's never the thing you'll say
right but they recognize you from there
what are you from I don't know Tropic
Thunder that's not it this is the end no
well I'm just getting older we're both
just getting closer to death here in
this conversation well that's the point
I like to get all my guests to on this
show we're all getting older and closer
to death
we'll take a break we'll be right back
buckle now you know that you you
obviously you have a bit of a Canadian
accent
and that's not news to you but I'm told
that you don't hear it when you when
you're doing hiccup when you're the
voice of hiccup in How to Train Your
Dragon movies but I understand that
you've you started to sneak it in a
little bit towards the end yeah I was
more just kind of like I stopped
listening to them when they would tell
me that I sounded Canadian you know so
like on the first movie I you know I've
got a lot to prove and want to impress
everybody and so every time they so you
said tomorrow you gotta say tomorrow or
something or you said sorry and we say
sorry and so all that stuff but then as
the movies went on I kind of just
stopped really caring and then I in fact
myself you would like proven yourself
though that's it and I you know and I
was like you know I I just decided a
certain point that he kept was Canadian
and I and you know there's I have I have
no there's no logic there's not a paper
trail behind that realization it's just
I just decided it and I remember in on
the third one
someone said I Jake we do another take
you sounded kind of Canadian there and I
kind of snapped as well were the Vikings
American I wasn't I wasn't aware that
that's that's what happened that's you
throwing a fit that's a very polite yeah
Jaber show fit you had there grounded in
historical accuracy as always